hello
everyone and welcome to today's live
broadcast
an insider's look how one parameter can
optimize key phases of bio processing
workflows
i am sabrina lemis of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's events
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by advanced instruments
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their site at
aicompanies.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
tara barrera director of cmc
operations at gemini therapeutics and
christina wright
application scientists at advanced
instruments
for a complete biography on our
presenters
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
para and christina you may now begin
your presentations welcome
thank you so much and thank you everyone
for joining us today
my name is christina wright i'm from
advanced instruments
um and i wanted to just kind of give an
overall
preview of what we'll be discussing
today before we jump into all the
exciting information we have to share
so what we'd really like to discuss is
how one
single parameter in this case osmolality
can be key to optimization of multiple
phases of your bioprocessing workflows
so let's just take a quick look at the
agenda for today
so first um i'll get a little bit of
background information including what
osmolality
is as a test i'd also like to get more
information from tara
and her background in the biotech world
then we'll look at osmolality across
different functional areas which i'm
really excited about
um tara is going to have a series of
vignettes
kind of some anecdotal evidence of how
osmolality testing has come into play
in her experiences and you can see that
there's
quite a few different areas that we're
going to touch upon so hopefully
one if not all of those areas will
resonate with our audience today
and then lastly we'll talk about how
advanced instruments can help
what is it that we can offer to make
sure that this test is as robust and
effective and efficient
as you need so with that being said
tara if you wouldn't mind just giving us
a little bit of
some background on yourself and kind of
how
how you came to be i guess in this
position to speak about osmolality
testing
thank you christina thank you for
inviting me to chat today and thank you
everyone for being here today
my name is tara barrera over the last 15
years in
biopharma and in the industry i've had
the pleasure of working across
all areas of the cmc value chain from
quality to early development to late
stage manufacturing
my background my degrees are in chemical
engineering
and i spent many of my early years in
the industry
on this in the cell culture suite focus
on development and scale up of processes
so
i'm kind of a bioreactor jockey these
days i have a much broader role as the
director of cmc operations managing
early and late stage
products and programs for a biotech
startup in the cambridge massachusetts
area
all right thank you so much tara for
that information
um like i mentioned before we kind of
jump into the meat
of our webinar and our conversation
today
i i didn't want to kind of bypass
what exactly osmolality is and why it's
relevant in this world of bioprocessing
so
let's just go back to some of the
fundamentals um osmolality
is actually a colligative property of
any liquid solution
so anytime you have the introduction of
solutes
into a liquid solvent that resulting
solution
is obviously going to differ from your
initial solvent in many many ways
osmolality is one of those ways and it's
really a way to measure concentration so
it represents the total number of
solutes in a solution
it's expressed as osmol of that of
your total solute per kilogram of
solvent
typically we'll see it as milliosmoles
per kilogram of water
that's how it would be represented
because osmolality
is not dependent on the volume of your
solution
it's not affected by a change in the
temperature of that solution which
becomes pretty relevant and kind of
unique
as an analytical measurement throughout
bioprocessing
and that's something that when we talk
about osmolarity versus osmolality
also sets those two properties apart
with that being said
let's talk about some of the functional
areas that tara and i will be discussing
today
in particular so the first is going to
be
an upstream we'll talk about how
osmolality shapes upstream
feed strategies um
additionally for upstream we'll talk a
little bit about
osmolality and media formulation
development
we'll also talk about formulation
development when it comes to
your drug substances even apart from the
upstream part of the process
and last but certainly certainly not
least we will talk about osmolality as
a measurement in stability and stability
studies
all right so
let's get started with
some conversation about upstream
processing
and i really tar i'm interested to know
more about osmolality and its role
across development areas today
in general
thanks christina uh yeah so i think
osmolality is one of those ubiquitous
measurements
that's present across all areas of
development and we can't really say that
for a lot of other analytics
so it's interesting how it comes into
play and i'm excited to talk about some
of the places i've used in the past and
some of the unlikely places we've used
it to help better understand our
processes
you know it certainly is an underrated
parameter um but i think
it's important especially in upstream
culture because
it's very reliable in terms of
measurement
awesome so i'm glad that you mentioned
that let's go ahead and like i said just
kind of jump into upstream can you tell
me a little bit more about where you
would typically see
osmolality testing in upstream
development
absolutely as many of you might know
cell culture is still a little bit of a
black box it's a mix of science and
superstition
um any cell culture scientists will
attest to this we all have our favorite
laminar flow hoods
our best culturing days the real
challenge in cell culture is that we
have minimal benchtop analytics and it's
a very dynamic process to try to keep
under control
we're typically using about a dozen or
so parameters to characterize what's
going on in the bioreactors and use that
to make assumptions on the health and
productivity of the culture
okay thank you that's really helpful so
i know you've had
about 15 years at this point of
experience in
upstream um would you be able to list
some of those parameters i know you said
there's quite a few but
um maybe some of the current parameters
for us all right quiz time uh we've got
ph dissolved oxygen dissolved co2
glucose lactate glutamine glutamate
ammonia and calcium um and of course
osmo
and then of course we have cell density
and viability or od
depending on what kind of culture you're
running okay so i ran out of fingers
that sounds like quite a few
it does you would think that but it's
really not right we still don't have a
great real-time protein assay for
products outside of maybe an igg
and it's really that's the whole point
of culture is to make your product
so we use these 12 or so parameters as
surrogate for hundreds of cellular
processes that go into making a protein
and that's why it feels like a place
where sometimes arts meet science
okay so can we dive a little bit deeper
into where osmolality would come into
play absolutely so
i see osmolality is one of the few
measurements we have in cell culture
that's multifactorial
it gives us a glimpse into the
parameters we can't measure
and what do i mean by multifactorial
well as we described earlier and how
osmolality works it takes the solution
as a whole
and it's not temperature dependent so
it's really a way that we can see
all of the solutes in the solution
without seeing them individually
when a development science is fleshing
out a feed strategy for a process we can
use
things like glucose uptake lactate
production and lactate
consumption and osmolality to see if
we're hitting that sweet spot for
feeding the cells
nice okay so what as far as
output or as you're tracking these
studies what does that
look like typically i'm glad you asked i
happen to bring some data with me today
wonderful
all right so what i'm showing here are
osmo traces and protein titer across a
14-day culture
benchtop analytics like i mentioned are
still a little light in the cell culture
arena so by looking at a multivariate
parameter like osmo you're taking into
account all the ions in solution
we understand how our cells are
responding to the feeds and how they're
utilizing
all the nutrients within those feeds
without having to measure each nutrient
individually
we can't get a really granular account
but rather a hundred foot view
as you can see across the final day of
culture the osmolality spans anywhere
from 400 to 500 depending on the feed
condition
and it looks like this condition in
light blue
is convent with the best production you
can see in the tighter graph on the
right the light blue line
is the one that's highest if we go to
the next slide i've got a couple more
graphs
to see how we can compare it to some of
our other analytics
the challenge with the glucose and
lactate parameters that i'm showing you
here
is that they're univariate it's only
telling us the glucose that's in
solution
and the lactate that's in solution as a
surrogate marker for
the rest of the cellular metabolism and
we see a pretty large spread across the
values
in glucose and then a smaller spread
across the lactate values
which is to be expected but isn't
necessarily guiding us to the same
conclusions that the osmolality did
and we wouldn't be able to zero in maybe
on a singular feed strategy here because
i probably would have discounted
a feed strategy that resulted in early
glucose accumulation
which is what we're seeing with the
light blue line on the glucose graph
right awesome okay that's really really
helpful thank you for um
providing us with some data to kind of
back up back up the story there
so that is certainly
a really intriguing use case and kind of
application
for oswality testing the
other area that i
mentioned to our audience earlier was
looking at the consistency of media
formulations
so if we kind of jump into that area
could you tell us a little bit about
how you can use osmolality as a as a
quality indicator for cell culture media
and for feed formulations
sure many median feeds come to us
as a powder ready to be hydrated for use
in our processes
any modern formulations unlike those in
the past
are just are generally just a few steps
and there's not really a lot of
granularity into the formulation
because commercial media companies don't
like to share the details of them
so we don't really have a great way of
knowing if it was prepared correctly or
if there are any issues with the lot
so one of our primary quality parameters
is
osmolality awesome
okay so do you typically see a lot of
variability
in the osmolality across your lot
no not if everything is going according
to plan
generally the osmo specifications on
commercial media when prepared correctly
are very accurate within the range
provided from the manufacturer
and that's great for us because it means
that we can have one parameter
that we rely on to consistently produce
batch after batch of cell culture media
okay so i'm noticing that you
keep emphasizing that as long as things
are prepared
correctly you know certain conditions
are true
so is there a story to this or
some more that you want to share
sure i'm glad you caught that about five
years ago i was working at a mid-sized
company in the upstream process
development department
in this particular company we used all
commercially available medias and feeds
that came in powder form to ensure that
when we transferred the process to our
manufacturing counterparts
the powder hydration process would also
scale up accordingly
one summer we had a very smart intern
and i mean it this kid was really
bright but a little too bright for his
own good a lot of times he would read
over our experimental plans and skip to
the good parts
modify them and execute the way he saw
fit i'll give him a lot of credit for
his confidence though
anyway one day we asked him to represent
media for our 100 liter stuff
and associated scale up so we're talking
about 150 liters of media it's
not an insignificant amount of media
that he has to make
the instructions for this hydration
and this particular media they tell you
to fill with water
whiffy or roadie whatever you're using
to 80 percent
and then add your powders and mix add
your ph adjustment and mix some more
and add one last p ph adjustment before
filling
the rest of the water because the
powders and
the ph adjustments take up some volume
and it's a little bit variable
so it's really important not to go to
full volume right off
the bat uh anyway he's
he's pretty smart he's pretty efficient
so he decided to add the full volume of
water up front
as all the powders mixes does the whole
process
get to the final step where we take the
ph and osmo to record in the lot
preparation log and once you know it's
osmo comes out
quite a bit lower than the acceptance
criteria
oh no yeah the 150 liters
gone to waste and he comes and lets us
know that the lot builds back and we're
trying to figure out why
we check the expert of the powder we
check other other
hydrated lots from the same company from
the same manufacturer
and see that they were all inspect so
we're starting to a full differential
we're getting really concerned that
there's something wrong with this media
a
lot
then one of our engineers notices that
we have
a bit more than 150 liters of media in
this bag
and we asked our interns did you
accidentally overfill on your qs
and as he's staring at us so confidently
he tells us that
he didn't have to do a qs and we're very
prolific and asked why not
and he said it seemed like an extra step
so he added all the volume up front
oh no well i'm sure that he certainly
will not forget that
and i am pretty certain that it also
will never happen again on his watch
you bet we made him dump that media and
reformulate it that day
which he wasn't that happy about but the
point is with the off the shelf media
you don't have a lot of checks and
balances because you don't
necessarily know what's in your powder
so osmo is a surefire way to make sure
that we're putting the right stuff in
the reactors
and that we're getting consistent media
formulation every single time
okay that makes perfect sense to me
and i think as we talk about
formulation um i know that
the area of your drug formulation
um for your either your drug product
your drug substance
is not definitely not the same as you
said is looking at something that's off
the shelf
that's kind of coming coming into your
area from a vendor
but despite how expansive this is
uh is there any way that you could tell
us
a little bit about maybe in general
um how osmolality kind of works its way
into drug formulation development as
well
oh wow yeah drug formulation development
is a pretty extensive area
where to begin right now i'm working at
a company that makes drugs for ocular
dosing
and that poses some pretty significant
challenges in formulation as you can
imagine
there's a lot of considerations when it
comes to what's acceptable and tolerable
in the eye
and i think it might be actually a
better story for a different day
because we don't have this kind of time
but i can tell you we're operating
within a very narrow
molality space for these ocular
formulations
okay that's that's really helpful to
know for sure and i
can completely understand um that this
is an
area that kind of requires its own
session
if you will um but that's really good
insight
and now that you say that tara i did
want to mention to
our audience today that
advanced instruments recently worked
with oxford global to hold a workshop
that covers
audibility testing in formulation
development
particularly within the vaccine field
which for obvious reasons
is really booming right now
but it's called improving your biologic
and advanced therapy drug formulation
strategy in a regulated world
so i will um make sure that we share
that
at at the end of this presentation um
when we open up for q a we'll make sure
that that's available to all of you
and i would definitely invite you to
check it out on demand it actually
just happened a couple of days ago it
was great we had some really great
speakers come
in um and some wonderful insight and
information was shared during that event
so
we'll put that link up just a little
plug right there
um but thank you again tara
for that information
so as i said last but certainly not
least
um we do want to talk about the area of
stability um so tara could you
talk to me a little bit about the
consistency
of an osmolality measurement um in
particular how it pertains to this area
and this really critical time for
testing
yeah definitely you know it really is
one of those types of things you can
rely on
uh with the osmolality measurements
there's not a lot of room for analyst
error
so if we get a measurement measurement
that's out of spec or out of tolerance
it's pretty likely to be a rational
result and
you know instantly i can think of two
examples
where osmolality measurement helped us
during an investigation into these out
of tolerance during a disability study
okay so could you describe
some of those sure
there's definitely a moment when you
review data and you say
yes there's a mistake in sample prep
here somewhere and i think
a lot of scientists a lot of formulation
scientists have had this moment
where you take a look at the
analyst data and you say there's no way
that's a real result
and because osmo values are so
consistent and
so reliable um you know this can this
can
trigger an investigation
so what is there a story there
what what do you mean by triggering an
investigation
absolutely so when you get one of these
errant values that ticks out like a sore
thumb
uh you know you get that data back in
your email and
you immediately say no stop stop the
presses we must look into this at one
company
i worked for we had a stability poll
where the osmo was significantly higher
than the anticipated value
we're talking about 50 osmo units higher
and
like i mentioned previously we have a
formulation
that goes into the eye so this this
would be this would be very
serious if this were an actual value we
reached out to our
internal qc team and we reviewed the
value
and even under our worst degradation
conditions
there's no way we would see osmolality
of all things
increase in our final drug formulation
so we launched a thorough investigation
at the testing lab and revealed that the
sample itself
going into the auto testing has been
contaminated with a different buffer
which completely skewed our results
now this was nothing earth-shattering
and was a really easy investigation to
close
because the analytical equipment and
simplicity of the test made it very
clear that the reported value
should have been interrogated and not
every app they had that so it's just a
simple
easy fix to something that was in the
moment a very stressful result
okay that's that's good that's a really
great example and i know
you mentioned earlier that you could
think of two examples so
if you want to share another story
absolutely this one's less
straightforward because it wasn't
a an error with the osmo value itself
um this is about a stability study we
were running on our bulk drug substance
samples
and when you run these bulk drug
substance stability studies you have
these small
sample vials um that are representative
of the much
larger storage containers for your drug
substance
in these small sample vials what we
didn't know is that there was a
manufacturer's defect
that made the caps on this particular
lot
difficult to torque so some of the caps
weren't seated properly but not
so unseated that there was a noticeable
so as the stability samples were filled
and stored
no one really noticed it so fast forward
to about three months
into our stability study where these
vials have been sitting
in a 25 degree c controlled chamber
and we start to see signs of evaporation
so how did you what kind of science how
did you know
well it started out as an official
investigation into a single time point
because the concentration measurement
on our drug substance was out of spec
according to the data
there's about a difference of 0.5 megs
per ml
over the specification and and that's
pretty high we don't generally
make drugs in a closed container
at that time we started to wonder if
something was going on with the
concentration assay because you wouldn't
expect it to be a measurable
evaporation in a field file like that
was
unheard the testing facility provided
pictures of vials
and on one or two of the pictures we
kind of noticed these skewed caps but we
couldn't tell if it was the angle of the
camera
or if it was that the cap was crooked or
or what we were seeing
and the pictures weren't really
definitive and we didn't have before and
after shots to compare so it was just
like
a decent theory that we were seeing
evaporation
okay so i'm thinking
osmolality absolutely
yes cosmo is one of those measurements
that is really beneficial
like we talked about earlier and can
pick up even small changes in solution
chemistry
so what we're able to do is as part of
the investigation
take additional osmo samples and reveal
that evaporation
was likely the root cause which would
have otherwise been a lot harder to
prove
because we didn't have before and after
pictures additionally we were able to
show that the actual bolstered substance
wasn't out of spec at all
and the large scale containers didn't
have torquing issues
and didn't have any of the torquing
issues that the small scale containers
did
and thankfully our drug substance was
okay
good so the batch was safe right
yeah you could say that our batch is
most definitely saved
thankfully we were able to close that
investigation using the osmo data
and other analytical data and keep our
drug substance on the shelf so it could
be filled and used in future clinical
trials
awesome awesome and i mean i i know it's
not
an easy thing necessarily to quantify
that
but i'm assuming that means because you
didn't have to
you know start from the beginning with
your study
that was able to save you a good amount
of time
and cost operational costs as well
absolutely i think anyone can tell you
you can't put a price
on investigational drug substance
there's there's just not enough money
for the time
the effort and the manufacturing costs
that go into it
great thank you so much tara this is um
extremely insightful um i know for me
and hopefully for those of you listening
so
with that um that kind of con concludes
our our vignette portion
um so we thank tara so much and um
what i'd like to get into now
is now that we understand osmolality as
a property
and we understand osmolality testing as
something that
clearly has value in different phases
of bioprocessing i'd like to just spend
a little time talking about
what advanced instruments can offer you
in terms of
measuring oscillating
so here you can see our current biotech
line of osmometers we have
two single sample micro osmometers the
osmotec
and our brand new osmotec xt
single sample micro osmometer i'll get
into that
um fresh new product in a second and
then we also have a multi-sample micro
osmometer
called the osmo tech pro
so just to give you an overview of some
of the
huge benefits of this portfolio
um we really want to highlight the ease
of use
so still very fast testing time
um that that you're used to
anywhere from 90 to 150 seconds
depending on the instrument
sample size so the two single sample
osmometers work with
20 microliters of sample and the osmotec
pro actually takes about 30 microliters
of sample
and then a touch screen which is now
used across
our biotech products obviously that will
help to optimize daily operations as
well as the workflow
and also consumable packaging is now
designed for
clean rooms so we keep our gmp friends
in mind
data management features so this has
been really
probably one of the the biggest driving
forces behind
our biotech portfolio is the data
management and data integrity
so there's more flexibility now with
data connectivity
you can push data straight to your
network if you use opc
that is an option there's even a remote
web server
where you can actually go to a website
let's say
on your phone from home and and see
what's going on with your results when
you're osmometer
secure and efficient management of
electronic data
is clearly becoming more and more
important
so that means it's of importance to us
as well and password protection for your
data security
data compliance getting a little bit
more into the integrity part and talking
about
21 cfr part 11. um or for those of you
in the eu annex 11 compliance
we do have a lot electronic signature
and we have a complete and comprehensive
audit trail and
lastly with the osmotec xt
we can now test even more sample types
so samples that may have previously been
more of an
issue with our technology
now we see the same performance and the
same robustness
out of uh our instruments with these
samples
as we would expect from any of the other
ai instruments so
with the xt you can now run up to 4 000
milliosmoles per kilogram and also you
have the ability to freeze more viscous
and and kind of complex samples if you
will
um and actually tara since you're here
i would love to kind of hear a little
bit about your experience
with osmometers in general with these
freezing point instruments
from advanced instruments i know that
you are a user
um could you just speak for a second
to the robustness of the instrument and
the reliability i know that you
mentioned that earlier during one of
your stories
oh absolutely i do have one question
first did you make your buzzing go away
[Laughter]
that would be amazing um you know the
buzzes are all a little bit different
so it's a little quieter
there's some nodding on these particular
instruments
i know we have some buzzing on other
instruments it's still there
um it's still a critical a critical part
of the
the freezing point measurement and the
technology but great questions
for those that aren't as familiar with
the freezing point technology it's
it's certainly a more accurate
technology
i'm a chemical engineer by training so i
love doing the back of the napkin osmo
calculation as much as the next person
but really having an accurate freezing
point osmo is super helpful
uh it's just that you have to freeze it
so these uh
these small you know compressors and
instruments that are used to freeze that
they kind of have a loud noise and
unexpected loud noise for those of you
who haven't used them
but as christina said these and i've
said
many many times these instruments are
very robust and really
break down maintenance is super simple
and the reagent is inexpensive
it's really a development scientist's
dream when it comes to equipment that
you have to maintain yourself
i remember back when i was at pfizer i
think we had what must have been one of
the original machines
and it was a real workhorse in the
development lab
it took up it took up about like i don't
know probably a third of a lab bench and
it
it had these trays that would run uh
like 12 samples at a time and you can
load it up with like four or five trays
and we would process dozens upon dozens
of samples
a day and rarely had any failures
um and then you know in my current role
um putting on my quality hat
i love that we have the 21 part 11
cfr compliance and the audit trail
capabilities with the newer machines
because
that's really made a difference in the
gmp suite so that we can collect this
data
in the development lab and then also
compare it to our gmp scale up which is
really important when we're trying to
get a product into the clinic
awesome that's great feedback so thank
you i definitely
we appreciate you sharing that um and
that's the goal
you know so ultimately we just want to
be able to keep up with
and and maybe even predict what our
customers are going to need in the
future
so with these instruments they're super
flexible even if it's not something that
pertains to your group right now
um it's likely that in in the coming you
know
year or two it could become more and
more intriguing and something that you
end up using in the future so thank you
tara
all right so outside of the instruments
themselves
just wanted to hit on some service and
support
um that we do offer along with our
devices
so we have installation and training by
manufacturer certified engineers we do
offer comprehensive iqot validation
so you know making sure that you are
able to get your device
online faster is important to you so
it's important to us
we do offer this service to our
customers as well as preventive
maintenance
so fully comprehensive service
contractor available to protect against
any downtime and make sure that you
are staying compliant with all of these
different regulations that we've
mentioned
and lastly very fast quick technical
support
um so we do often offer
um service techs and managers that are
available
for you to communicate with and we can
get someone out to you the very next
working day
if you have any issues
so i mentioned the osmotec xt
um which is now available for pre-sale i
did just want to
kind of show this off a little bit
because it is new so
this is definitely a one-of-a-kind
osmometer
specifically designed for biotech and
again um
meets all the needs but really we're
trying to bring in a space
and a device that can keep up with
different sample types because
we're seeing more concentrated drug
substances
we're seeing a lot more viscous
excipients for example
cryopreservatives so this has really
great performance that you'd be used to
but now across a greater range and like
i mentioned
you can now test more complex and
diverse sample types so
drug formulations different compounds
cryopreservatives
any of your nucleic acids
or protein therapeutics whatever your
solution
the idea here is that we can cover them
all and cover them all with great
performance
and again of course we've talked about
21cfr part 11.
still holds true with the osmotec xt
so with that i just want to thank you
again and you can see on this slide our
website where you can find out more
about all of our
biotech osmometers as well as some of
the applications that we've discussed
today
and with that tara and i
would love to take any questions that
you guys have
thank you tara and christina for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for
so the first question i see coming in
um this person says that they do not
really understand or see the correlation
between the cell titer and osmolarity
in your graph how exactly do
i have to adapt my feeding strategy to
osmolarity
and they also say or feed when a certain
value
is reached
that's a really good question um and
thanks for submitting that
so one of the things um you know
obviously the data that i presented here
is a
quick snapshot from all the data that we
collected on that batch
so there's other indicators i think you
know with the
message and the point that i would
convey around using osmo for feed
strategy is
you know you can look at glucose than
lactate and glucose is a great trigger
for triggering when to feed
but osmo can tell you the overall health
of the cells and and generally with
mammalian cell culture
you know we're keeping those osmo values
between 350 and 450
and you know even if you're using up all
of your glucose but your
osmo is creeping up beyond that 450
range you might want to adjust your feed
strategy down
conversely if you're you know kind of
thinking and dipping below the 350 range
you may want to
increase your feed strategy up as well
as looking at your other parameters that
are accessible to you
hopefully that answers the question but
i'm happy to follow up more
wonderful thank you so much um the next
one i have coming
in as to the unexpected increase
of the osmo osmality value
as what is expected can result to
unexpected reactions
how can we minimize those kinds of cases
i think i understand this question so
if you're if you're asking you know
unexpected increasing
leading to unexpected reactions
within i'm guessing you're saying like
within the formulation itself
or maybe unexpected or i don't know if
you're referring to unexpected human
reactions
um but i'm assuming you're talking
within the formulation itself and and i
think
you know looking you know
taking more data points as you're
leading up into
um some some of that
uh you know some of that data so like
more frequent sampling can help you
before you
hit a trigger point that would lead to
other chemical reactions within the
formulation
i think that's answering the question
i'm not
quite sure but we can follow up on that
as well
yes absolutely the next one i have
how do freeze point osmo instruments
differ from vapor pressure units
and then they say from a sample fit data
and use
perspective not mechanical
okay um i'll take that so great question
um but i do think that a lot of the
differences are associated with the
mechanical differences
so um freezing point and vapor pressure
instruments are thermometers are
actually looking at different
properties of the same solutions right
so
um to answer your question without
getting
too specific because it honestly will
depend on the type of solution that
you're working with
um so there are some samples for which
we see
you know very little difference um and
then there are some that we might see
a a greater i guess bias if you would
simply because they're measuring them in
different ways
um so what we like
to really highlight especially with the
xt
uh because the formulation area where
there's
really concentrated proteins um there's
a lot of excipients like sugars and
things that might kind of complicate it
as far as the freezing method or even
something like a cryopreservative
even if there are those differences it's
between the two instruments
um with the xt we definitely offer that
precision
that you need to give you confidence
that that is
the correct value so hopefully
to answer your question without kind of
getting into the mechanics of it
it's going to depend on what you're
looking at so if you're looking at a
more simple solution with one
solute probably less likely to really
see any difference
compared to something in a formulation
but i can't really give you an exact
amount of units but thank you that's a
great question
thank you and this one is um geared
towards tara
it says tara thanks for the data on feed
strategy i'm curious if you're able to
use this work
to tell what's going on on based osmo
for example
um is a change by a certain amount
indicates
indicative of a specific analyte
changing
that's a that's also a great question so
there are theoretical osmo values for a
lot of
common analytes uh for example
you know glucose we generally as a rule
of thumb use five and a half
osmo units and for lactate about 11.
uh those you know it can vary a little
bit from the
calculated and the actual freezing point
asthma so
so you can use those and you can sort of
see an osmo increase and make some
educated assumptions as to what's
increasing or decreasing based on
other measurable parameters as well so
most definitely
great and we have time for a few more
questions this one says new to oz
osmality here how many stability time
points
would you recommend for a vaccine
and gene therapy product for eg a three
year study
yeah i mean i think osmo's certainly one
of the things that you test on stability
and the stability study that you design
is is very product and program specific
i think generally speaking in a three
year study
you have time points at like 0 1
3 6 9 12
15 18 24 and 36 months but again
again it depends on your formulation uh
the impact of stability
on your ability to dose in the clinic
and what your degradation pathways are
for your product you may have more time
points if you're
if you have an unstable product you may
have less time points if you have a very
stable product so
it's highly variable and osmo's just one
of those considerations
and it's usually measured at every time
point because
it's generally a low volume sample so um
it's it's always great to be able to get
that data at every time point
thank you okay we're going to wrap up
with this final question i want to
remind our audience that those questions
we are unable to answer today and those
that come in during the
on-demand period will be answered by the
speaker via the email address you
provided at the time of registration
so this question says for what areas
mentioned today do you suggest the xt
model
so i would say i mean honestly to not to
over simplify but really any area
because of its ability to kind of span
the concentration range
and also to look at some of those more
complex or more viscous samples it's
appropriate for it for
everything um i think what we had in
mind
right and the development of this model
was certainly the areas that i mentioned
um within formulation and kind of taking
into consideration the
excipients and the the more concentrated
solutions that we're starting to see in
the industry
um you know that could also come into
play
in downstream in downstream processing
so
if you're starting with more
concentrated buffers and doing some
in-line dilution studies
this not only will address some of the
higher concentrations but if it's
something that's a little bit more
viscous
again this instrument will be really
great
as far as compensating for that and
knowing exactly
how to freeze that type of sample so it
could be
anywhere um it's just really expanding
the different types of solutions that
we're able to
not only you know freeze and get our the
the technology to work with the engine
but also to do so precisely and really
give you a measurement that you can be
confident
in
thank you again tara and christina do
you have any final comments for our
audience
uh yeah i'd just like to say thank you
to everyone who tuned in today
and certainly if you have more questions
please send them we're more than happy
to answer them and
provide feedback based on our
experiences so thank you
yes i i'd like to echo that sentiment um
tara thank you so much
and um to all those listening and in the
audience they
really appreciate it um and and like
tara said please feel free to reach out
if anything else pops into your head or
if you
have any follow-up questions
wonderful before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today
and their interesting questions
questions again that we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank tara
and christina for their time today and
their important research
and we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor advanced
instruments for underwriting today's
educational webcast you can view the
webinar on demand
and libraries will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
that is all for now have a great day
until next time goodbye